beyond the Neon
beneath the concrete the haunted history
of the Las Vegas Strip runs deep look at
where our feet are there's so much more
underneath this than asphalt and
concrete there's land and we go back 10
000 years we talk about the Paiute
Indians that were here and
a lot of innocent blood was probably
spilled and there are certain things
that affect the land so we start way
back 700 A.D and the history is
fascinating and frightening but experts
like Tandy of U.S Ghost Adventures would
say Don't run and hide allow them to be
your ghostly guide you know just like
people every city has a soul and a past
and skeletons in their closet or wax
figures in a museum the Venetian is home
to America's First Madame tussos so you
better keep your head up when you see
them two of the most active figures
within the wax museum are Tupac and
Angelina now Tupac's unsolved murder
happened very close to the location of
where his wax figure is Tupac over a
period of time his hands rested like
this his head like this and over several
months period his head lifted five
degrees and His Hands came up two inches
and in the words of two Tupac Life Goes
On especially at the Flamingo every
possible thing went wrong for Bugsy
he opened the flamingo on a day that was
not a good day to open it there was this
terrible freak rainstorm almost like it
was planned
and nobody showed he'd also gone over
budget and he wasn't very good at
numbers
so a few months later he was killed shot
dead in his girlfriend Virginia Hills
Beverly Hills mansion but back in Vegas
the ghost of mobster Bugsy Siegel still
throws now Bugsy as we said was a little
forgetful
while me we may forget our keys or where
we put our glasses Bugsy sometimes
forgot to put a body
in one of the trap doors and he would
come back in the room understandably
would smell so bad you couldn't tolerate
it and that's what two of our newlywed
guests smelled when they stayed in the
presidential room and I dare you to look
in mirrors where her spirit may still
Loom we had a real estate developer who
stayed at the Flamingo and he'd worked
hard all week a little tired
he was almost ready to go home and he
came and went into the bathroom
sort of stumbling for the light switch
he turned it on and to
and horror
he did not see his own face looking back
at him if you smell cigars by the
Flamingo pool that could be Bugsy trying
to scare us but now
let's head to the Harris the previous
owner Shelby Williams met his demise six
months before Harris was completed
now many many people see Mr Williams
you'll hear him he'll get off the
elevator and he'll just he's an audible
Specter and he'll say at least it's
finished you are now immersed in the
spirit and the spirits of the Las Vegas
Strip where ghosts leave blood still
drips
[Music]